welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
i spoke with ben greenfield
ben's a biohacker human body and brain
performance coach
ex-bodybuilder iron man triathlete
speaker and author
we discussed diet of course i asked
about the impact of emf
like wi-fi 5g and bluetooth because
there are people who are up in arms
about this stuff
and given the fact i've been only eating
meat for three years and thriving
i honestly don't know what information
to trust anymore and have gone with
trust nothing and nobody so we covered
emf
what kind of water he drinks structured
water what that is
methylene blue nad grounding pads
we went in deep into biohacking in here
this episode is brought to you by the
meat company true local
i'm a huge fan of true local they
connect you with local farmers and ship
you their meat
i love that but there's also new news
mark who's the ceo and co-founder great
entrepreneurial dude who wants to help
the world with good food and sustainable
food sold the company although he's
still running it and now they're able to
branch out to more places in the states
and the random remote areas of canada
that i really can't believe people still
live in
or perhaps it's better to live there now
that the world is insane anyway
congratulations mark that's super cool
they're a great super fast way to get
high quality sustainable meat in your
home
and with code mp you can get free steaks
i recommend their lamb
turkey ribeye strip loins and wild
salmon it's where i get
meat in a box every two weeks for the
last two and a half years
consistently high quality code mp true
local t-r-u-local.ca i hope you enjoy
this episode have a good week
remember to subscribe if you
like it and leave a rating if you're on
apple podcast
if you'd be so kind i hope you liked the
episode
and greenfield welcome to my podcast hey
thanks for having me sorry i'm so late
that's okay i wasn't in a rush and i've
been looking forward to speaking with
you so i would have waited longer
i gave you a chance to make tea exactly
now i have my tea
look what kind of tea do you drink i'm
so i've been through your book obviously
and this isn't snazzy tea i think right
now it's earl grey
and it's honestly it's not even great
earl grey it's got natural flavors in
there so who knows what that is but
it tastes good and i'm not quite as
optimized as you are
yet but maybe after this conversation
i'll be closer to that point earl grey
sounds kind of boring i'm incapable of
making tea without just
messing it up with it with a ton of
extra ingredients so i'll give it a tea
bag but then i'll grab
like another tea bag if i grab nettle
then i'll grab licorice
and then some cinnamon sounds good and
then i'll put some turmeric in there
and then sip it and realize i need to
add some stevia
and maybe some monk fruit and then some
sea salt by the time i finish making tea
it's got like 12 different things in it
because i just i don't know tea
one tea bag is just too boring for me ah
okay
see i only ate beef for like a year and
a half
and then i added in lamb and so now that
i'm at tea
it's like it's huge so just starting
with
one ingredient i started with peppermint
i was like just adding peppermint
diversifies my diet insanely so
i'm still at the few few ingredient tea
level
that's a big step that's a big step i
did something pretty cool with beef last
night i made beef uh
boring neon i don't even know if i'm
pronouncing that properly
it's like a uh it's like a french recipe
a classic
winter time stew and it was so good
i'm actually really looking forward to
lunch today it's just
it's basically i have a whole freezer
full of stew meat and it's really hard
to make stew meat actually taste good
like it's it's kind of a
kind of a tougher cut but
what you do with this this french beef
dish
is you brown it with bacon fat so i had
a bunch of uncured bacon slabs
i chopped all that up and then browned
the beef and the bacon fat
with a little bit of butter which
automatically uh will
will uh start to make stuff taste good
and then
yeah um put a bunch of bone broth
and some red wine and some brandy into
this giant
dutch pot with the with the browned uh
beef and the bacon fat and then a bunch
of pearl onions
some minced garlic some carrots
some salt some pepper some bay leaves a
little bit of thyme a little bit of
rosemary
and then uh just put it in the oven for
about an hour and a half
in this dutch oven and then uh you know
a lot of uh a lot of the stuff i like to
do on cooking
i try to stay you know as natural as
possible
and so the the trick is you got to get
this stuff to thicken up
afterwards to make it you know to give
that nice thick stewie texture
and it turns out one french method for
doing that is you can take mushrooms
and just like saute a bunch of mushrooms
in butter and then put those back
into the pot and it thickens the stew
after you've made it
so i got a bunch of cremini mushrooms
cooked them up in
more butter and then put that in the
stew after it finished
and oh my goodness it was so so good
so um so i'm right there on the beef
bandwagon but i
i like to do a lot more with my beef
yeah well i did too
except they made me hallucinate at one
point so i put an end to that
real fast i'm i'm much more healed
from that stage of my life so but i
haven't gone back to
vegetables dad other than my earl grade
tea which i'm
massively enjoying i made a chicken
liver
pate yesterday oh my gosh which was
amazing it's not something i thought i
would eat but it was great chicken
liver pate and jerky that's my snack
right now yeah i um
i figured out this deal with liver all
and it sounds kind of gross
but it's actually really good because a
lot of times in the morning i have a
smoothie i'll just do like bone broth
with some collagen
sometimes a little stevia or monk fruit
some some ice
and and maybe like some cacao powder or
something to give it a little bit more
of like an ice cream-ish flavor
and um with the uh with the smoothie
i figured out you can take liver and
puree it
pour it into into molds and then freeze
it and you can have like these little
frozen liver bites that you can drop
into your smoothie
you don't even really taste the liver
but oh my goodness the
the uh the vitamin status of your
smoothie goes to the roof obviously
that's kind of a cool way to have your
liver and and you know disguise it kind
of like
you know my parents used to put
vegetables you know all minced and
pureed into our spaghetti sauce
yeah huh i've never i haven't tried that
i was not a huge liver
fan and then you know the longer you
only eat one thing it's like liver
starts to look pretty tasty
but chicken liver is new and it's been
fantastic
so i wanted to ask you because i've
talked to a number of
biohackers or health optimization people
before
but your book i have it here boundless
this massive textbook has
information about everything and more in
there
so i wanted to cover some of the things
i haven't really covered before
uh starting with your thoughts on emf
what that is why we could start there uh
and and whether or not people should be
concerned about it
okay well there's there's obviously a
lot that's been written on emfs
that uh that goes above and beyond what
i cover in the book but
you know the main thing is that you know
like when i built the house
that we're living in now i really wanted
to take into account not just things
like
you know the air quality you know with
really good built-in hepa air filtration
systems and
you know negative ion generators and a
lot of the stuff can just that can just
make the air
super clean and very much like you would
you know get on a on
a mountain top but i wanted to have
really good water so i did like a
a really good uh carbon block filtration
system for
well water and then that passes through
like a structured water unit
to to structure the water with which
arguably
can allow it to hydrate you a little bit
better based on some of the research
that
dr gerald pollock has done up at
university of washington
on on the so-called exclusion zone of
water
yeah i want to get into that too
yeah yeah so so i did i kind of want to
optimize the air
and the water and then a lot of the
lighting
it's all you know natural lighting very
very circadian rhythm friendly lighting
meaning i chose
primarily incandescent bulbs that don't
produce a ton of blue light
and even a lot of the bedrooms like my
kids bedroom and
our bedroom and our master bathrooms
those are all like red incandescent
lights
so it's a little bit more like something
you would get from say
you know torchlight or fire light you
know something that really doesn't
disrupt
your circadian rhythm or down regulate
melatonin production
and then the last thing i want to do is
just make sure that it was as natural as
possible when it comes to
the amount of so-called non-native
electricity
that my body was exposed to during the
day meaning like you know
the earth is chock-full of the
electricity you know anytime lightning
strikes the earth you're you're charging
the planet with negative ions you know
we know that the geological formations
all
all across the surface of the earth
those are all emitting what's called
ems these pulsed magnetic frequencies
usually in the range of
like 10 hertz uh up to around 100 hertz
or so
so we're constantly connected to
electricity especially for like walking
outside barefoot
or you know climbing trees rocks things
like that but then
if you increase the the power
and the hertz frequency through the roof
such as you would get from like a wi-fi
router
or a cell phone or you know a ton of
appliances
running up ac currents you're pretty
much surrounded by
a lot of electricity that arguably from
kind of an ancestral standpoint
are our cells haven't really evolved to
be able to deal with so
what what happens is you get some amount
of
of dna damage and protein and unfolding
in response to
some of the um some of these signals but
then you get an
uh an increase in what's called the
calcium channel
activity across the cell membrane so you
get kind of a steep influx of calcium
into the cell
which can limit metabolic activity to a
certain extent
and then you also see a see a big
turnover
in a lot of the the enzymes
and the compounds responsible for doing
things like repairing dna or
or managing the calcium uh
the the the calcium balance across the
cell so you see like a depletion of nad
or you see a depletion of a lot of these
these sirtuins that help to repair dna
you see a depletion of magnesium and so
so there is kind of a biological impact
of that constant exposure to some of
these higher frequencies
and higher powers when it comes to to
emf so
for example what i did in my house was i
opted not to have
a wi-fi router i just i hardwired
everything with with a
metal shielded cat 7 ethernet cable
so whenever you want to use the internet
you can just plug into the wall
you know and there's a cable in every
room and and a port
so you know i've got no wi-fi signal to
deal with and
in the book i explain how you know even
if even if you
don't have that option and you're
running your house on a wi-fi router
you can at least turn it off at night
like you can plug your wi-fi router
into say something like a digital wall
timer which is not that expensive on
amazon
and you just program the digital wall
timer to turn off at 10 pm
and turn on again at 6am so at least
during like the third of your life
when you're in bed sleeping when a lot
of your nervous system repair and
recovery takes place
when you wouldn't want to be bombarded
by a lot of those signals
you're not because the wi-fi router is
off um
you know in addition to that i've got a
lot of these these little uh
dongles that convert ethernet to uh
to iphone so when i want to do iphone
updates when i want to talk on the phone
like a lot of times i can't even talk to
my phone when it's hardwired
so i'm getting subjected to a lot fewer
cell phone and cell phone tower signals
um you know there's a there's a lot when
it comes to
like satellites and cell phone towers
that you can't control as far as a lot
of these signals that are just coming in
through your house and so
um you know there are some pretty
extreme measures i get into in the book
that you can do like you can
you can literally like have a have
faraday
paint in certain areas of your home that
you're spending a lot of time in
you know like the bedroom for example um
you can um use like these these canopies
that you can put around your bed
that kind of shield you while you're
asleep and i realize a lot of this stuff
sounds kind of like tinfoil hattie but
when i'm at home
i feel amazing like i i sleep way better
than when i travel
um my my body recovers faster
after workouts i don't get as much like
brain fog
and kind of cognitive fatigue later in
the afternoon i think a big part of it
is i'm just not
constantly exposed to all these kind of
higher frequency
higher power signals that would be
considered non-native emf
but probably the two i would say in
addition what i get into in that chapter
the book where i talk about air
and light and water and electricity as
being four
things that that you should be just as
serious about
controlling in your environment as say
like nutrition
and movement i would say in addition to
that chapter two really good books out
there right now would be
uh nick pennell has a book called the
non-tinfoil hat guide to emf
and then um dr joe mercola has a book
it's also got a great title his book is
called
emf'd and both of those books go into
a lot more about the biological impact a
lot of the research on the biological
impact
and then a lot of kind of the mitigation
methods that you can use to
to just just kind of protect yourself
and and so uh
so yeah i think it's an issue and i'm
certainly cognizant about it
yeah okay so i've i've i already felt
tin foil
hatty enough on an all meat diet to
you know initially heal my autoimmune
and mood disorders plethora of
other problems uh so i didn't want to
kind of
delve into that because when one of the
reasons was
i can't find any solid i'm not that
there's studies on the carnivore diet
right so i'm kind of beyond the whole
study thing but
i couldn't find anything solid that
compared people say that
we're less like less that didn't live in
a house with wi-fi versus people who
lived in a house with wi-fi
so i've never come across anything solid
that actually compared someone in a low
emf
environment to somebody in a high emf
environment and saw differences
is there anything like that or is this a
lot of this based on how people feel
in both those books i said particularly
mercola's latest book he actually has a
lot of research that he cites
i i think that some of the failures lie
in in people kind of citing
uh potential for damage when it hasn't
been proven like 5g for example there's
actually not a lot of evidence that 5g
is bad for you
there's not a lot of evidence that that
is good for you either but
you know it's kind of like the jury's
out on that particular
um like small millimeter wavelength so
i'm personally just careful about it you
know i i yeah i do have 5g
disabled on my phone you know just using
like 4g lte
i think is is the is the version that my
phone's on right now
just because i want to wait for more
studies to come out but yeah there are a
lot of studies that exist on say
um wi-fi signals there's some on uh on
the red blood cell interaction
with bluetooth and some of the heating
of some of the uh
some of the neural tissue with things
like you know bluetooth earbuds and
things like that so i don't i don't use
a lot of bluetooth
for that reason um you know i don't i
don't
i try to minimize the amount of uh
time i'm near wi-fi router at least
increase my distance from a router from
having to use it
um and yeah i'm i'm pretty careful and
then of course there's just kind of the
whole
you know strain from scientism just the
whole
anecdotal piece you know how do you feel
if you implement at least a few of these
tricks
and if you feel pretty good then you
know that that's a little bit of an
answer right there of course you know
there's always the placebo effect
whenever you're doing anecdotal
n equals one studies on yourself but you
know i
i'm i'm convinced enough that it does
something to be aware
of especially for kids with rapidly
dividing you know cells and
thinner skulls and a lot of the issues
with kids that you know
for my boys you know i'm just happy that
they're you know when they go to bed at
night it's like
you know it's all super clean air it's
all red light
you know there's no signals bouncing
around their room and you know
and they they just sleep like babies
like nine to ten hours a night and they
wake up and they've got
great physical function and great
cognitive function and you know they do
eat a healthy diet and they
they exercise and there's lots of love
in our home but i think they also just
have a really clean
personal environment and that helps out
quite a bit too
i had an interesting experience the
other week i haven't
it's been like three years of my deep
sleep being at
you know one to four percent just
absolutely terrible
um and a lot of that had to do with
stress i figured but then
in the last couple of weeks i got an air
purifier
like a good air purifier and put it
beside my bed and my
deep sleep jumped from an average of
four percent to 17
in a day uh which was incredible to me
because i live in a fairly new condo
i've moved
right um there isn't mold i don't have
any pets
uh it shouldn't be low quality air but
that was pretty interesting to me that
it affected my sleep quality so much
yeah it is interesting and sometimes
some of those newer nice air filters
they'll
they'll churn out what i mentioned
earlier those negative ions
which normally you'd breathe in more
dense amounts of those if you're like
walking along the beach or near the
ocean
or outdoors and so if you're introducing
those into your personal environment you
might just be creating a more natural
sleeping environment but that's really
interesting i haven't heard that about
air filters in terms of deep sleep
percentages
but you know this especially if your air
quality wasn't super poor
but it's good to know yeah yeah it
really surprised me but it's been
uh two and a half years of me monitoring
sleep with
four percent level of deep sleep and
it's gone to 17 it doesn't make and i
got an air filter so i think that was
the cause
um water so you talk about
structured water what is that
yeah so so like when you look at water
in nature and let's say it's tumbling
over rocks you know
down a down a creek or in an underground
spring
you tend to see a a high amount of
what's called
exclusion zone which is basically um
if you if you look at water as it
travels through
a vessel you know exclusion zone means
there's kind of a positive charge
towards the outside walls of that vessel
and a little bit more of a negative
charge
on the inside and because of that it
means
there is bonding that creates almost
like this crystalline structure
a lot of the h2o molecules that goes
above and beyond
just the the bonding of oxygen to
hydrogen and it's kind of interesting
because if you look at
at plants and the way that water travels
up through plants you know against
gravity a large part of that
is due to that electrical pull created
by the exclusion zone you know because
like plants don't have a heart
to to pump water but the water is moving
along this electrical gradient and when
you look at
um for example that university of
washington researchers who i mentioned
dr gerald pollock who has a few great
books out
kind of explain the science behind this
you know he'll do studies in his lab
where
not only will he show that water that's
been vortexed
meaning what happens is if you spiral
water um
through typically that's done by passing
it through a series of like small rocks
or small glass beads
it's like a tubular shaped filter what
happens is the water
that's been structured in that manner
travels a lot more quickly and readily
up like the small glass pipettes
that'll study the water in and it's
interesting because if you expose the
water to infrared light
like sunlight it does that even more
readily meaning
that you know say like plants that
are naturally structuring their water
and getting exposed to sunlight
kind of have this natural hydration
mechanism built in
and humans can actually do the same as a
matter of fact there's a
book by dr thomas cowan about this from
a cardiovascular standpoint
how your heart the shape of your heart
is actually kind of designed
it's it's what's called a
tetrahedron-like shape and it vortices
the actual blood
that travels through your heart meaning
it creates an exclusion zone almost like
structures your blood
very similar to what a structured water
filter does and so
what that means is that if you are
say out in the sunlight a lot or using
some of these infrared light panels or
infrared saunas or whatever
you're actually equipping your body to
become a little bit more hydrated just
based on
on the movement of water through the
system it takes a little bit of a load
off the heart
so it's super interesting but for your
own home you can do the same thing just
for the water you shower in
or the water you drink like i mentioned
i'd i have a well
and a lot of people are under the
mistaken impression that well water is
just naturally
pristine and clean but like i have a lot
of um
bacterial based iron in my water which
could potentially put me at a risk for
you know what they call hemochromatosis
or you know rusting out of the inside of
the body from excess
iron intake so i want to filter the iron
now i also have really high levels of
manganese
in the well water and because i'm
i'm kind of below a bunch of farmland i
even get a little bit nervous about
glyphosate or
herbicide and pesticide runoff so what i
do is
is i filter my water through a carbon
block filter
but anytime water gets gets filtered
like that and then
sits in a pipe or in a cistern or a
collecting tank for a certain period of
time
you lose a lot of that structuring just
because the water's not moving so
what happens is after the water travels
through the carbon block then it goes
through
those series of glass beads like it's
called a structured water filter
that restructures the water so the water
that i'm drinking
or showering in etc it's actually just a
little bit closer to nature
and it's allowing me to drink this water
that has a natural
exclusion zone in it so arguably i'm a
little bit better hydrated
you know my dad is the person who taught
me about this because when i was growing
up
he was a gourmet coffee roaster and he
also
was really into like espresso
preparation coffee preparation cupping
coffee tasting you know special machine
repair and he works a lot of local
coffee shops
and besides the actual quality of the
bean itself
he found the number one way to improve
the quality of the cupping experience
for the espresso experience
was with the water that was used and and
he tested a ton of different water
filtration systems and found
that when he would use structured water
uh for espresso
or for coffee the the flavor and the
consistency
of the brew was way way better and so
he eventually he actually got out of the
coffee business and he got in the water
business and now he builds like these
giant structured water units for farms
and
agricultural facilities and i mean that
the yield
on uh agriculture on plants
the the size and the growth rate of
a lot of the um like particularly the
cattle that
are drinking this water is it's actually
pretty impressive
so i've just kind of learned a lot about
structured water from him
and then also from a lot of dr gerald
pollock's research and um
i think it's i think it's kind of a cool
little way to to upgrade your water
so to speak you can naturally experience
what
this is like for yourself if you add
some minerals to water which are going
to help out
in terms of carrying that charge or or
kind of like uh
electrically charging water so if you
add like a few pinches of let's say like
celtic salt
to your water and then you set out in
the sunlight because the infrared rays
from the sunlight
are going to help create that charge
separation
and then you drink that water out of
let's say like a large mason glass jar
versus just a regular glass of water
that hasn't had the minerals or the
infrared light added to it
you'll you'll kind of taste the
difference between drinking naturally
structured water
versus regular just kind of flat water
so it actually is a pretty profound
difference so i start off every morning
with just a
giant mason glass jar of that structured
water and you know i had a little bit of
vitamin c and
baking soda to it and then all the water
i drink during the day
you know if it's not because i'm kind of
a sucker for uh for pellegrino
i do i do like me a few bottles of
pellegrino during the day but if i'm not
drinking pellegrino it's just all
structured water from my faucet okay i
was gonna ask what happens if you take
structured water and then you carbonate
it
does that wreck it i don't know i i
would not imagine
that the introduction of co2 or a lot of
these these
you know bubbly water manufacturers
they'll use like a citric acid
bicarbonate solution
to make the water bubbly i don't i don't
see any mechanism via which that would
reduce
the amount of of the charge separation
or the exclusion zone that's created by
structuring water
but i also haven't seen see much data on
that so i'm not sure
yeah question i survive off of like san
pellegrino and
mixed with electrolytes i actually have
uh electrolytes coming out in march
from a mixture that i've been using for
the last couple of years
and you mentioned that you add stevia
these ones like the flavored ones have
a little bit of stevia i i used it
because i know it doesn't spike
blood sugar levels and you can use just
like the tiniest amount to change flavor
but why do you use it um in your
well you're right whatever you're
drinking i don't need a lot of stevia
it's like 100 depending on the type you
use like a hundred to a thousand times
sweeter
than sugar but doesn't have the glycemic
impact of sugar
because it's non-caloric but it comes
from a stevia leaf i mean it's a
it's a natural extract versus say like
acid potassium or sucralose or
or aspartame or some of these other
compounds that have been shown to be
problematic for your gut biome
and may also have a little a little bit
of a neurotoxic effect
you know kind of similar to like high
amounts of of uh msg or monosodium
glutamate
and so um i like stevia
and i also like monk fruit as two really
natural sweeteners and actually that's
one of my favorite things to do it's
like a vanilla cream soda
i get really good organic stevia there's
a company called
omica organics and they make a vanilla
stevia
and a butterscotch toffee stevia and
i'll put like a few drops of that
into a giant glass bottle of pellegrino
and it literally just tastes like
vanilla cream soda and so
i use a i use a lot of stevia in that or
like in my
morning smoothie for example monk fruit
sweetener is pretty good too um i
actually do this little
little kind of like nootropic pick-me-up
blend where i get
some liquid pure nicotine like without
the vegetable glycerin and everything
in it and then a little bit of methylene
blue which is actually really really
good for your mitochondria
and i'll do a little bit of methylene
blue and
a little bit of nicotine and then some
of that monk fruit
or stevia sweetener and i'll put that in
like a little
like a like a squirt bottle that you can
spread your tongue like a breath
freshener and
due to a couple sprays of that and
you're flying high for a couple of hours
it's actually kind of a cool little
neutral pecan to mix methylene blue oh
and nicotine
that is cool stevia yeah it's like penny
a dollar
wow okay so more about this methylene
blue i somebody mentioned it on a
previous podcast i know i've seen it on
instagram like you take it turns your
tongue blue
so what is that how does it work yeah it
interacts with a part of the
mitochondria called cytochrome c oxidase
and if you can increase the activity of
cytochrome c
oxidase your mitochondria should turn
out more atp and it turns out the
methylene blue
is one of the most potent ways to do
that and not only that
interesting because we've already
visited this topic once um
when you're you have methylene blue in
your system
one of the ways that it will bind a
little bit better
to the cytochrome c oxidase system is if
you're also exposed to infrared light
or sunlight and so you know for example
you can take some methylene blue and if
you have access to an infrared sauna
or if you can get out in the sunlight or
anything like that you're going to
produce more
atp with the methylene blue in your
system it's actually kind of interesting
there's a there's a book it's a little
bit tough to get to because i think it's
a russian translation but it's called
human photosynthesis
and it kind of gets into this idea of
how humans can
photosynthesize in response to sunlight
a little bit similarly to plants
due to the the protein melanin
um on our skin and to a certain extent
on our vasculature as well
and so if you have high amounts of
melanin and then you get exposed to
infrared light
you can produce more atp and it turns
out that there are certain things
that can increase that electron
shuttling to produce more atp
methylene blue is one of them but then
anything that has melanin in it
and one thing that's really really high
in melanin is actually um
chaga mushroom like chaga extract and so
that's another cool thing that you can
do is you can like drink a nice
nice big dense cup of chaga tea and then
go for a walk in the sun
it's one of the best ways to to amp up
your energy levels the same thing if
you're one of those people who likes to
use an infrared sauna
or any of these new kind of like
infrared light panels that are really
popular
if you take methylene blue or drink a
cup of chaga tea beforehand
the amount of energy you get from that
type of infrared light exposure is even
even greater so it's actually a pretty
remarkable difference in terms of how i
feel subjectively if i'll
do chaga or methylene and then get out
in sunshine or use one of these infrared
saunas
so and it's just really really great
particularly
um for mental energy you know the same
thing people would be looking for from a
cup of coffee or a smart drug or
microdose or a
nootropic you can get from a from a
simple little hack like that
wow okay i found that from my or you
guess you could call it health journey
or
health stumble or whatever uh i found
that nutrition was
absolutely number one right getting off
all the medications and nutrition
uh and then the infrared sauna made a
huge difference especially when i was
feeling terrible
um you talk about infrared sauna and
then you also talk about light panels
and i have some you have some red like
right in the background there
uh what are the benefits of those and
have you
like can you feel the difference can you
feel it right away did it take you a
while to notice
what's your experience with those yeah
you're right nutrition is pretty
important
um movement you know slash exercise
is also pretty important but then i
think you know returning back to what we
touched on earlier how you need to be
kind of cognizant of
your light your air your water and the
amount of non-native electricity you're
exposed to
if you want to kind of put the icing on
the cake i think the same could be said
for some of these other modalities like
you have nutrition
and movement but then i think a lot of
people would benefit from doing more
heat and cold or like a lot more sauna
a lot more coal just because of the
production of you know these heat shock
proteins and
cold shock proteins and increase in
blood flow and decrease in inflammation
and a lot of the stuff that you get from
a from a regular sauna
or cold practice you know i could be
everything from wim hof to a
you know nightly visit to the to the
sauna or at least hitting sauna
four to five times a week uh which which
appears to be kind of the sweet spot
based on a lot of the longevity research
that they've done over in over in
finland and so you know heat and cold is
important i think being outside you know
earthing and grounding
returning back to some of those natural
electrical signals produced by the earth
some of those negative ions they get
exposed to i think that's also
very important and often underemphasized
um
i think exposure to sunlight along with
drinking really good
clear clean mineral rich structured
water
is also really important when it comes
to just like off neglected
things for health that a lot of people
don't even think of you know versus just
going to the gym
and eating healthy bro and so part of
that
would be when it comes to the light
component um
infrared light like it turns out that
that the near the far
and the red spectrum of infrared light
can do everything from improved thyroid
function
to um increased collagen and elastin
production
um for men it's been shown to increase
activity the latex cells in the testes
so there's a little bit of a bump up
uh in testosterone production um you see
an improvement in sleep quality
if it's combined with heat such as you
might get with an infrared sauna
the penetration the light through the
skin can induce a little bit more of a
deep sweat
and a little bit more of a of a seeping
of metals and toxins through the skin
than you get from a dry sauna and so
there's a lot of benefits
especially with regular sauna use i
actually have a little podcast coming
out on this soon about you know the
the enormous amount of benefits when you
get
the production of these heat chuck
proteins in response to heat
along with a lot of the things that
happen when the skin gets exposed to
infrared light
and it's it's it's pretty fantastic in
terms of like red blood cell production
and maintenance of muscle mass and
sometimes even growth of muscle
um you know decrease in injury rate
improvement in sleep quality
and so you know i'm usually like for me
30 40 minutes four to five times a week
in the sauna in my basement and almost
always
outside into some super cold cold plunge
afterwards
and i feel like a million bucks with
that type of protocol
and i i like the infrared even better
than i do the dry sauna because
you're getting the best of both worlds
getting both heat as well as light
and if you have a dry sauna or access to
a dry sauna you can arguably
get like some heat resistant infrared
bulbs
and put those in a dry sun and get the
best of both worlds if you want both
heat
and light but you know i'm a huge fan of
both sunlight
as well as these infrared light panels
as well as infrared light saunas for for
harnessing a lot of those benefits
so you mentioned faraday cage and so
faraday cage
is something that blocks emf from
penetrating whatever you put this
faraday around right so
if you were to put your phone for
example in like a you know because
because a
lot of companies now that sell emf
blocking gear or clothing or
you may have heard like you know like
there's a couple lambs that does like
emf blocking underwear
but some of them will sell little um
like um bags or purses you can put your
phone into if you want to reduce
your cell phone signal and some of the
good ones like you can't even receive a
call
when when your phone is placed inside
one of those bags so it just kind of
shields you
with the idea being of course you know
it can be kind of annoying if you're
whatever wanted to play on your phone in
bed and you're in a faraday cage you're
not gonna get that great of a signal if
you get a signal at all
um however you're also you know it's
like
it's like you're on a pristine himalayan
mountain top just kind of
kind of blocked off from a lot of these
signals from radio towers or cell phone
towers or
satellites or or you know anything else
that you might be
constantly getting bombarded with
because like i'm not a luddite like i
embrace technology and it's a
huge part of my business and my life you
know being able to
use social media and you know and blog
and
podcasts and all these things but i just
try to to mitigate the damage here and
there
where i can so yeah i'll use i'll use
faraday caging
and then you know like i mentioned
you'll see that
um you get an increased turnover of some
pretty important dna protective
compounds like nad
like sirtuins like magnesium
particularly
and an up regulation of a lot of these
inflammatory pathways you know one
called the
the nf kappa b pathway for example and
it's kind of interesting because
a lot of those inflammatory pathway
increases are modulated by
either ketosis or the intake of
exogenous ketones so like if i'm
traveling
say in airbnbs where i don't have a lot
of say over the wi-fi router
or i'm on you know on a long-haul flight
where i'm just getting bombarded by
signals the whole time
like i will i'll take nad i'll take
magnesium
i'll take some type of of circuit enzyme
like resveratrol or blueberry powder or
something like that
and then i'll take ketones and that's
kind of like my my go-to
travel hack for minimizing the effects
of a lot of this
this radiation so how do you take nad
i'm traveling i just have like a little
patch i put on my thigh
because it turns out like a lot of
people get the ivs because you'll get a
lot higher levels
i've had those yeah and i do but you
obviously can't get any stock
might be on a plane but um there are
companies that sell electrophoresis
patches like nad patches
that just kind of slow bleed them into
your system the entire time you're say
on a flight for example so that's that's
my preferred method
you know you you can take nad orally or
nr
you know or nmn you know different
variants of nad or even arguably just
like niacinamide
which is dirt cheap and and could work
almost just as well
and you know any of those methods for
oral administration
you do see some loss just due to to the
need for
for passing through the through the
digestive tract and you know gastric
past
and so if you can get it through your
skin or straight into your bloodstream
it's a little bit better delivery
mechanism or a net like a nasal spray
a lot of companies like uh i think alive
by nature is one now
they'll send uh or they'll sell nasal
sprays there's even a doctor in florida
who um you know i met him he does a lot
of work with cancer patients and i found
out he does a lot of kind of like
biohacking and really cool alternative
delivery methods
and almost all of his nad his smart
drugs his nootropics his
um like his dna repair type of compounds
all that stuff he
they're almost all nasal spray or
suppository
so he's pretty much delivering through
the nasal mucosa or through the rectal
mucosa
um and yeah you can actually get really
good delivery via either of those
methods as well
yeah that makes sense i think i have a
alive by nature
nmn and our sublingual stuff yeah yeah
that's like the one that you dissolve in
your mouth that's that's a pretty good
one
and actually compared to nicotinamide
riboside
which is like what chromadex is selling
and is is pretty popular
it appears nmn actually does a better
job
crossing the blood-brain barrier and
winding up in in your hypothalamus
particularly
so if you're doing this for for the
neural protective function you'd want to
do like an nad nasal spray
or like in like a nmn that dissolves in
your mouth versus say like
an nr capsule okay
uh back to structured water for a second
what what could people potentially do
if they say live in a condo or is there
some sort of filter they can use that's
either portable or yeah they have like
pour over filters poor restructured
water filter yeah
i travel with one of those uh you can
get like under the sink filters
um those are probably the two best
methods
uh they also have shower filters a lot
of people don't think about that but i
mean your skin's kind of a giant mouth
and so i'm i'm into actually having some
type of a shower head filter
that will either filter the water or
structure the water or both
and those are pretty pretty easy to get
to i mean you could google structured
water shower head filter
or structured water countertop filter or
under the sink filter
or or structure water pour over and yeah
there's a variety of companies that will
sell that stuff
cool okay next topic grounding do those
grounding pads
actually do anything are they worth it
what do they do if they do anything
yeah i mean like i mentioned you know
the earth is going to emit
around 10 to 100 hertz frequencies so if
you're outside barefoot
or laying on your back on the beach or
swimming in the ocean is really good
because you're getting the combination
of the minerals
along with the electricity uh there
actually is a pretty
pretty potent anti-inflammatory effect
there's a really great book about this
called
grounding and a documentary by the same
name
actually it might be called earthing i
don't remember but anyways
um the uh the idea is that
you obviously aren't gonna spend your
whole life outside barefoot unless
you're some you know indigenous
hunter-gatherer tribe or something like
that
and so in my office i've got one of
these mats
that plugs into the i well it can you
can go two ways
it can either feed out into your
backyard and just you just put a stake
into the ground
and the wire goes from the stake into
the mat and so you're getting the same
type of ionic exposure
while you're standing indoors as you
would be if you're standing outdoors
that's one way to do it
and if your house is properly grounded
if you have a properly grounded outlet
you can just plug
the mat into a grounded outlet and and
also get the same effect
the concern is that if you're in a
highly
um urban area with a ton of ac
signals that are traveling through the
ground or traveling through your home's
electrical system
you could be getting exposed to to a
wide number of power surges you know
because some of these mats they'll sell
to put underneath your top sheet and
sleep on during the night or be standing
on
all day while you're at work now because
i live like
pretty isolated out in the forest i'm
not concerned about those type of power
surges
and hefty ac currents but i'd say it
depends like if you're
kind of out on your own in a pretty low
emf
area anyways the use of those grounding
maps just allows you to
be inside getting all the same benefits
as you would be getting
if you're outside barefoot but if you're
in like a big city
in a really urban area with you know a
hefty power grid
i think you could be exposing yourself
to a lot more power surges
by using those uh and so it just kind of
depends on where you live
whether or not you get benefit from them
and you know you can also
um you can grind your shoes like like
they sell little shoe grounding straps
uh i was watching uh i think it was a
nadal
um zhiakovich on uh
played tennis and he actually had a
couple of grounding straps
on his uh on his tennis shoes and you
can just take any
big old you know rubber built up sole
that would normally not conduct
electricity
and put one of these grounding straps
underneath it and go for a walk with
that
and again get exposed to a lot of these
these negative ions
that the earth emits and that same
pulsed electromagnetic frequency
that the earth emits and if you look up
a lot of like physical therapy clinics
or
you know regenerative medicine clinics
or injury management clinics
a lot of them will even use pemf as a
modality for healing and injury
or for decreasing inflammation it's kind
of the same concept it's just
you know it's way lower intensity than
what you get from a wi-fi router or
something like that so
it's more native to the human body but
actually does a really good job
opening and closing cell membranes and
allowing for reduction in inflammation
so it can be
kind of a good hack for injuries as well
okay
uh let's jump over to nutrition for a
little bit um
what what is it is there a diet you
follow is there a diet you recommend
people
try or is there a way of eating you
think is optimal
what do you do no i
i don't think there's any one diet that
fits everybody
even though it's you know kind of a dark
dirty secret in the nutrition industry
that if you want to make a bunch of
money
you write a diet book and then you tell
everybody this is like
the one diet that will cure all of
humankind when
based on biochemical individuality
meaning everything from like
differentiations and in the rate at
which we excrete oxalates or
retain or excrete vitamin d based on
different microbiome profiles
in the gut you know how how well we can
metabolize carbohydrates how much
carbohydrates might cause
you know some type of blood sugar
excursion versus how normalized
someone's blood sugar might be even in
response to say like a a cookie or a
banana
um you know differences in
um you know gut health the way that a
gut might respond
if a gut has been compromised to have
the amounts of raw vegetables or fiber
versus how uh how you know a gut that
doesn't have a leaky lining
would respond to those you know there's
just so many variations
in biochemistry in genetics and in gut
health particularly
that dictate that you know the diet that
that works for
your neighbor might not work for you
like you take like a ketogenic diet
and you know that that might have helped
your neighbor lose 20 pounds
or whatever but let's say you have
familial hypercholesterolemia
where you have a poorly functioning
gallbladder so you don't have a lot of
bile
for for uh for digesting fat
or um you have let's say like an apoe44
gene
that would predispose you to some amount
of neural inflammation particularly in
response to
a high level of saturated fat which is
quite characteristic of a lot of these
ketogenic diets
then you might be screwing yourself over
metabolically
with the same diet that was healthy for
your neighbor
and so you know i i think that the best
way to choose a diet that would be
appropriate for you
would be to get a gut panel like a
really good stool panel that will
identify things like
you know digestive enzyme
insufficiencies or the presence or
absence of inflammation
or leaky gut get a good genetic analysis
so you can look at different pathways
and look at not only what your ancestors
might have eaten which arguably
would dictate that you might be better
equipped to eat those type of foods
but then also you know it allows you to
look at everything from you know vitamin
d pathways how fast you metabolize
caffeine to a host of things that will
influence your dietary decisions and
then something like a blood panel you
know a full lipid panel
uh you know complete bud count comprise
a metabolic panel
you know a thyroid panel just everything
that will allow you to make better
decisions
from a supplementation standpoint um or
or a you know fat intake or carb intake
standpoint
and then some type of micronutrient
panel like there's one called a neutral
valve that's really good
you know these are the same type of
tests that you know an executive would
have paid
tens of thousands of dollars for like
the you know prince and longevity
institute
you know a couple of decades ago now you
can get you know for
not that expensive just order to your
own house you can you can do a lot of
these tests
on yourself and once you have that data
and there's actually a whole section in
the back of my book where i say okay
so here's what your blood looks like
here's what your gut looks like here's
your saliva
your urine your genes here's the diet
that's probably gonna be best for you
and you know with the clients i work
with in that book
i find you know generally when you look
at diets like
the carnivore diet the paleo diet maybe
an autoimmune diet
some type of vegan diet you know and and
just kind of picking and choosing from
the variety of diets out there i think i
i wound up with about 12 different diets
that would would be available to choose
from
based on your unique profile and then
you you choose the diet
that that is actually appropriate to you
so that's kind of the way
that that i approach structuring diet
now that being said um
possibly because humans may have
originated from the from the fertile
crescent area
of the planet earth it appears that some
semblance of a mediterranean diet
tends to over and over again especially
and even like large-scale research
be generally the most healthy
particularly from a cardiovascular
health standpoint
for the widest variety of people and
you know of course there are aspects to
a mediterranean diet such as fasting
you know religion um in many cases you
know eating with people
eating a lot of wild plants and herbs
and spices you know micro doses of
alcohol intake
you know things like that that dictate
that you know a true mediterranean diet
might not necessarily be the feta cheese
olive garden you know
cups and cups of olive oil diet that
some people might be consuming on a
on a bastardized version of a
mediterranean diet but if somebody asked
me there's like what diet can i follow
i don't know anything about him i tell
him well i don't know but you know
a lot of people do pretty well with with
some type of a mediterranean diet
and then you know when you look at a lot
of the best practices of just about any
successful diet out there beyond protein
fat carb or macronutrient percentages
um you know beyond the the composition
of the diet itself
you tend to see regular patterns emerge
over and over again
for example some semblance of fasting
right either intermittent fasting or
some type of a
religious fast built into the calendar
some periods of
reduced calorie or compressed calorie
feeding windows like you you see that in
just about every successful diet
you know no matter where it's carnivore
or paleo or vegan or whatever um
you tend to see that food is eaten in a
relatively parasympathetic state
right not not shoving food down the
hatch while you're
driving down the highway stressed in
traffic but typically eating
slowly chewing each bite many many times
eating with people
visiting with people not kind of like
eating as a as an afterthought
in a completely unmindful way say during
work or hunched over your computer
and so you tend to see mindful eating
with people
in a parasympathetic state some
semblance of fasting
very low intake of processed or packaged
foods
very low intake of linoleic acid and
vegetable oils
particularly you know seed and vegetable
processed oils you know you'll see a lot
of
the healthiest diets are maybe getting
max you know two to three grams
of vegetable oil and those even those
usually aren't from from heavily
processed
seed and nut based oils such as canola
or sunflower
safflower but aren't set for more
natural sources
um and you tend to see
a low amount of glycemic variability not
necessarily low carb
but at least um some amount of blood
sugar stabilization from
eating foods slowly eating foods that
have been fermented
or soaked or sprouted or cured um
eating foods that that are not ultra
processed you know most of the
carbohydrates are
what are called cellular versus
acellular meaning the carbohydrate
walls are intact and they take they're a
little bit more slow to digest a little
bit more nutrient dense typically
um and in many cases a wide variety of
of
of foods in general like a wide variety
of plants and herbs and spices and
granted in some cases these foods are
used as medicines
not as foods in some cases these foods
are restricted
in people who have a compromised diet or
who are unable to handle a lot of kind
of
the built-in natural plant defense
mechanisms that
would make a healthy person stronger but
that would make an
unhealthy person feel sick in their gut
and so
you know when you look at the dietary
patterns you know you'll
you'll see a lot of healthy patterns
emerge no matter the carb protein and
fat percentages
and so i realize this is a long answer
but if you can do some self-testing you
know genetics blood saliva urine stool
customize your diet to you and then no
matter what diet you choose
incorporate fasting eating in a
parasympathetic state
eating real whole recognizable food
avoiding vegetable oils like the plague
and being cognizant of the amount of you
know kind of glycemic surge excursions
or
you know glycemic variability you know
blood sugar roller coaster rides that
you might be on
you're you're kind of on the right track
to a diet that's going to work for you
yeah i find the obviously i'm
pro-carnivore diet
but i find but i find that most of the
people who end up
gravitating towards it have got there
because they're desperate like most
people don't jump on board because
they're interested in limiting their
diet
they jump on board because they're
already pretty damaged right
i mean i got here because i had like
a whole bunch of auto major autoimmune
problems mood disorder i was on seven
medications um
that i probably stopped taking too
suddenly i had neurological damage and
it was like
i need to fix myself now um
but i like most of the people i see
doing the carnivore diet
have either taken some medication or are
on medication
and they're pretty ill people so i think
that's
rather than being optimal diet for
humans as a whole
i think it works really well for one
identifying what the problem is
allowing people to heal their gut get
off medications and it gives people a
good starting point if they can't afford
or don't know where to start of of
course there's your book to help but
don't know where to start with testing
or how to
to even identify what the tests mean
yeah it's kind of like an elimination
diet
in that sense yeah yeah um it's kind of
interesting because
it's very close to the way that i eat
this this carnivore diet approach i mean
my diet
is mostly nose-to-tail meats i do a ton
of organ meats you know liver
heart kidney i love to order stuff like
the braun schweiger and head cheese from
us wellness meats
i get a lot of food from belcampo meats
i bow hunt
and so i typically got wild game you
know venison particularly
and and organs from that in the freezer
i also go to hawaii a couple times a
year to hunt and i get
sheep and goat and turkey and access
deer
down there and bring that back in
coolers and um
so i've typically got a freezer full of
meat and i do a lot of notes to tell
me including chicken fish and then most
of my carbohydrates are underground
storage organs you know carrots
parsnips sweet potatoes yams i do very
few grains if i do any grain
typically it's millet which is kind of a
naturally very low gluten ancient grain
sometimes a little bit of a himalayan
tartary buckwheat which is also an
extremely antioxidant rich
very gut friendly grain and those are
about the only two kind of like grainy
type of foods that i'll consume and then
a little bit of honey
a little bit of berries a lot of bone
broth and um
that's kind of the majority of my diet
is nose-to-tail organ meats tubers honey
berries
bone broth and i'm i feel really good
on that type of diet and you know
arguably
it's kind of like a keto carnivore diet
because
you know at this point especially since
i'm not competing professionally in
endurance sports anymore which i did for
the past 20 years starting this past
year i kind of hung up the hat on that
and so i'm eating like maximum maybe 50
grams of carbs a day
and so i'm i'm mostly just like kind of
keto carnivore-ish that's that's
the diet that works pretty well for me
yeah that's what i'm hoping i'm slowly
working towards that like the longer i'm
on this
uh contrary to popular belief the less
sensitive i get
so for the first while it was beef only
which is really a miserable diet
uh and then it was beefal lamb and now
it's beef and lemon tea
and i can you know if i have some herbs
or something
touch it i don't have this giant
horrible neurological and autoimmune
response
um and i find a lot of people who are
reintroducing foods if they start with
something like cooked carrots
parsnips or maybe a little bit of cooked
apple
like those are the kind of vegetables
that are
or plant foods that seem to be really
easy to
start with for people who have extreme
sensitivities you ever mess around much
with colostrum
no i'm so scared i'm dairy was so
poisonous to me
and i don't know if it is anymore and
i've been told you know it depends on
the type of dairy and all these things
but it was
so severe that i'm just like plus
there's not a lot of dairy proteins in
colostrum
and i've found for a lot of people are
reintroducing foods um
doing like a decent dose of colostrum in
the morning and evening
and the the salivary enzymes in your
mouth kind of activate a lot of the
growth factors and gut healing
components of colostrum
i actually find for people who are
introducing foods like introducing
colostrum at the same time
that you start to introduce new foods
makes them far less problematic
um even if you're very sensitive there's
you know you don't have a lot of lactose
sugars and dairy proteins in colostrum
particularly
and is there is there colostrum you can
get from animals other than dairy
animals
like goat or something yeah yeah you can
get go like there's a farm
by my house that's a goat classroom yeah
easy to find
it's tempting i just don't want to
experience like i seem to have two sets
of symptoms i have the neurological
component which is worse and then they
i have the arthritic component so i
tried to reintroduce plants in the
summer
and the neurological component seems to
have healed quite a bit
but then the arthritis was still there
yeah just like these these two
issues well i mean if you if you were
willing to go on a limb and try it you
could at least
see if you're symptomatic and if you are
then there's your answer right there
yeah that's true if the neurological
symptoms aren't there it's not as scary
uh you don't think there's then there's
this other part of me that thinks
maybe people aren't really supposed to
be eating that much dairy if at all
given the fact that we're the only
animals that do that and i know that
there's the other argument saying well
we've built ourselves to be able to
consume milk from other animals but
you know you get told that about eating
processed foods nowadays too
well humans are incredibly versatile and
i mean i have a couple thoughts
you know we're also the only animal
flies giant you know metal tubes across
the sky 40 000 feet above the planet and
yet that seems to have served us pretty
well from from general standpoint and
then i also
you know as a christian and a believer
in the dominion mandate in the bible
that kind of our first job was was
almost a garden and to learn a lot about
nature
and to find find a good use for a lot of
animals on the planet and then you look
through a lot of the rest of biblical
literature and you find
you know milk and honey and you know
high-fat
animal foods and a lot of these things
being considered as like the ultimate
way that god blesses people
it kind of makes me think well why would
god you know bless people
with milk and honey and then we would
turn around
you know in the 21st century and say
fructose is poison and humans aren't
supposed to eat milk so some of it for
me
you know i realize i get pushed back
from people who don't like that a you
know scientific nutritionist guy
believes in a magical god fairy in the
sky but i do
and so you know part of it for me you
know i look at what the bible says and
i'm like well
you know god blesses people with milk
and honey so why leave those components
out of my diet unless
they're highly problematic yeah well
they certainly taste good
i will at some point i'll do it but i
haven't even gone to butter yet
it was so bad the arthritis and the
neurological stuff was so bad from dairy
and i wasn't eating high quality dairy
or probably wasn't dairy from the right
cow but it was so awful that i would
have put it in the same kind of reaction
as gluten
which was just like deadly to me yeah
yeah well you know your body you should
listen to it
yeah my body's crazy it's less crazy now
uh okay okay um what's what are your
thought
actually let's do this first have you
ever done any of these you know
biohacking or health optimization
because you've done a lot of
experimenting have any of the
experiments gone very wrong
no people ask that question a lot and i
want to hear a disaster story make up a
story some
sexy wounded healer story but i mean
honestly no
like i had way more problems back when i
was racing iron man and doing adventure
races you know
swimming up river until i was blue in
the face and
you know crapping my wetsuit in the car
and um
you know just getting crazy bike crashes
out in the middle of thailand and middle
of nowhere and
you know a lot of dirt bike racing and
you know i've had
you know tons of concussions and and
contusions and you know
all sorts of crazy stuff but bio hacking
i honestly
i really have not messed myself up at
all
with something like that i mean you know
i i guess you know maybe you know in the
in the realm of like microdosing and
psychoactives
and determining appropriate dosages you
know i've
accidentally done the math wrong and you
know taking like
heroic dosages of mushrooms or you know
psilocybin on a work day just because i
i did my calculation right little things
like that but even that i mean you you
know
you go to bed and have a nice meditation
session and it's not like you're scarred
for life
yeah okay well i know we're running out
of time so where can people find you if
they somehow haven't heard of you
well you mentioned the book so that's a
good spot um
which is at boundlessbook.com and then i
do
an article every tuesday and every
sunday usually tuesdays more health
science fitness sundays are a little
more religious
spirituality based that's at ben
greenfieldfitness.com
uh twice a week i release a podcast
interview with some scientist or
physiologist or physician
or athlete or you know somebody who
would never give me the time of day
unless they were actually
being interviewed by me on a podcast and
those are fun i feel bad it was a
couple times a week and um yeah so i'd
say ben greenfieldfitness.com is a good
spot i'm on
instagram and all that stuff too okay
well thank you very much for coming on
cool thanks for having me on mikayla i
appreciate it
you